there's a miniature rocket ship and it's
full of tiny aliens that just got done
investigating a new moon with lunar
pools and all kinds of organic new
life-forms but they're done
investigating so they're going to blast
off and take their findings home to tell
all their friends let's say at some
moment during their ascent they're
moving at 4 meters per second and their
tiny aliens their spaceship is only 2.9
kilograms but they need to know are they
going to be able to get off this moon or
not so they've got to pay attention to
their speed but instead of using a
speedometer the clever aliens they use a
force versus time graph so on their
dashboard that we've got a force versus
time graph and it tells them what the
net force is on them so let's say this
is the net force not just any force this
is the total force on them from rocket
boosters and the force of gravity and
whatever other forces there might be
they've got too advanced for sensors I
mean come on they can determine their
net force let's say and it gives them
this force as a function of time but
they want to know what is their velocity
going to be after 9 seconds so they
check their force versus time readout
and this is the graph they get and now
they can determine it and here's how
they do it they say alright there's a
force a net force of 3 Newtons acting
for the first 4 seconds so that during
this entire first 4 seconds there's a
constant force of 3 Newtons and every
alien worth his weight knows that force
the net force multiplied by the time
duration during which that force is
applied gives you the net impulse so
this gives us the net impulse if we take
this constant 3 Newtons that acts
multiplied by four seconds during which
it acts we get that there's an impulse
of 12 Newton seconds now you might be
like wait who cares about Newton's
seconds here I want the velocity I don't
care about the force and the time I want
to know the velocity at 9 seconds but
they teach you at the alien space
Academy that the net impulse is not only
equal to the net force times the time
it's also equal to the change in
momentum of the object that the force
was exerted on and this is good we know
the mass of the object we want to know
something about velocity so we know
momentum is M times V this net impulse
is going to help us
get there but this 12 Newton seconds was
only for the first 4 seconds how do we
figure it out for the next three seconds
leave this during the next 3 seconds
there's not a constant force this force
is varying the force is getting smaller
so how do I do this the force isn't a
constant value so I can't just simply
take Force Times time because I mean
what force do I pick so we're going to
use a trick we're going to use a trick
because if you notice for this first
section for the first four seconds
we took the force and multiplied by the
time interval four seconds so what we
did really is we just took the height of
this rectangle times the width of this
rectangle and that gives us the area of
this rectangle so what we really did is
we found the area under the force versus
time graph that gave us the impulse and
that's not a coincidence
the impulse equals the area under a
force versus time graph and this is
extremely useful to know because now in
this section where the force was varying
we can still use this we can just find
the impulse by determining the area
under that curve and by area under the
curve we mean from the line curve in
general to the x-axis which in this case
the x-axis is of the time axis so let's
do this we found the impulse for this
first section that was 12 Newton seconds
now we can find the impulse for this
next section by just determining the
area so this is a triangle we'll do one
half base the base is 1 2 3 seconds and
the height is still 3 Newton's so we get
a net impulse of 4.5 Newton seconds so
if you've got one more section to go but
this one's a little weird this one's
located the area is located below the
time axis so this is still a triangle
but since the forces are negative this
is going to count as a negative net
impulse so when the area lies above the
time axis it counts as a positive
impulse and when the area lies below the
time axis it counts as a negative net
impulse so how much negative net impulse
we still find the area so the area of a
triangle again is going to be 1/2 the
base this time is 2 seconds and the
height is negative 2 so negative 2
Newtons which gives us a net in Pole
of negative to newton-seconds and now we
can figure out the velocity of this
spaceship at nine seconds so assuming
that this force readout started at this
moment right over here at T equals zero
seconds was the moment when it was going
four meters per second then we can just
say the total net impulse should equal
the total change in momentum of the
spaceship and we can find the total net
impulse by just adding up all the
individual impulses so during the first
four seconds there was 12 Newton seconds
of impulse during the next three seconds
there was 4.5 Newton seconds of impulse
and during this last portion there was
negative 2 Newton seconds of impulse
which if you add all those up 12 plus
4.5 plus negative 2 you're going to get
positive 14.5 Newton seconds of impulse
that's good news for our alien buddies
over here they need to get off this moon
which means they need positive impulse
upward impulse they got some positive
impulse let's see what their final
velocity was we know that Delta P is the
change in momentum so this is final
momentum minus initial momentum which we
could write as mass times V final minus
mass times V initial now if this were an
earth rocket this would be hard because
earth rockets using earth technology
eject fuel at a huge rate out the back
end and that loses mass that means this
mass isn't going to stay constant so
earth Rockets essentially push fuel down
which causes an equal and opposite force
back on the rocket upward but if you're
losing mass this mass doesn't stay
constant and this whole process is a lot
harder because M final and M initial
aren't going to be the same maybe this
is where the phrase it's not rocket
science comes from because rocket
science is a little harder when that
mass changes so let's just say these
clever aliens can eject only a little
bit of fuel they do so you might say how
well there's got to be a certain amount
of momentum right that they eject to
give themselves momentum up but let's
say they can eject only a small mass at
a huge speed so there's not much fuel
that they're losing the fuel that they
eject is ejected at the enormous speed
so that they get their momentum upward
but they lose almost no mass and that
lets us solve this problem a soon
the mass is constant so if we do that if
we assume the mass is constant we get
positive 14.5 Newton's seconds equals we
can pull the mass out the masses of
constant so I could just write it as M
times V final minus V initial since I
can pull out a common factor of M which
means I can write this as 2.9 kilograms
multiplied by the final velocity after 9
seconds and I know it's after 9 seconds
because I added up all the impulse
during the 9 seconds minus the initial
velocity was 4 meters per second so if I
divide both sides by 2.9 kilograms 14.5
over 2.9 is 5 and that will be Newton
seconds over kilograms which has units
of meters per second and it's positive
that's going to equal the left over over
here is going to be V final minus 4
meters per second and now finally if I
add 4 meters per second to both sides I
get that V final somewhere up here the
final of this rocket is going to be 9
meters per second so after 9 seconds it
ended up going 9 meters per second
that's just a numerical coincidence the
way you find it so recapping the way we
did this we found the area under the
curve because the area under a curve
under our force versus time graph
represents the impulse on the object we
found it for the entire trip noting that
underneath the time axis when this curve
goes underneath the time axis the net
impulse is going to be negative we added
up all the net impulse we set it equal
to the change in momentum we plugged in
our values and we solved for our final
velocity after 9 seconds